super excited that Matt Hanson was able
to make the way up from DC just moved to
University of Maryland last year this
year actually from South Dakota he's a
really globally recognized leader in
land cover modeling among other things
but that's what he's really famous for
and we've heard from would you already
how remote sensing really in a way
equalizes the globe all the way from the
tropics to the high latitudes I think we
all can't believe in this global vision
of parties assimilated who remote
sensing data that is so global and so
high quality and and map is one of the
leading thinkers in global land cover
modeling so thank you ma'am thank you
very much world for including me in the
symposium i'm sorry i missed yesterday I
would have enjoyed very much learning
because I am a bit removed from this
Community I'm going to be talking about
our land cover and change mapping
capabilities and how we're getting down
to a granularity had a global scale
where we think that the data are going
to have very very be very useful to to
modeling aspirations in the biodiversity
community and we do work with
conservation groups a lot of this work
was derived from products projects in
central Africa based on with the focus
on conservation mapping of last intact
forest landscapes nets or thing so a lot
of it has to do with biodiversity
conservation and we've scaled it
globally that's that's another track is
trying to make globally consistent
products that have local relevance and
you'll see if if we're making progress
there as I go through the talk I'd like
to acknowledge Peter but top off use
really implementing advancing a lot of
the products you're going to see in this
talk that is it is a consortium of
different groups we have Google Earth
doing a lot of processing for us in
parallel with our capabilities and I'd
like to highlight obviously NASA all of
this results all of the vision for
emphasizing global scale monitoring the
land it comes from massive programs and
all these results are the result of NASA
support real quickly in 1994 colleagues
of mine and my former committee actually
John Townsend and Ruth the freeze of
University of Maryland made a one degree
by one degree lion cover map was 360 by
180 pixels in 1994 and they got they
published in the international journal
of remote sensing as a big deal you can
imagine
small that file is in the how blocky and
unsatisfying that kind of depictions but
that's that's where we were in the mid
90s and so that's that square as big as
square and then we advanced with a
meteorological satellite avhrr and we
were working a kilometer in one
kilometer by the close of the millennium
and then modus went up modus is a land
monitor has land bands anyway to 500 250
meters so through the first decade of
this century we are going down to 500
meters 250 meters getting into looking
at change more clearly because you get
more discreet finer scale resolution you
can start mapping change then is what he
eluded they opened up the Landsat
archive three years ago and now our
aspiration and we've got some prototypes
but we're just working on this idea of
mapping repeatedly the globe at 30
meters Heidi again of having a global
algorithm that gives you a global
synthesis is very nice when we cut out
any particular it has local relevance
that's our goal and and of course when
you're working at a park boundary or
you're working inside a you know intact
forest having these type of disturbance
data and you can compare them across
countries and and parks and that sort of
thing is very important but anyway where
are we going to be in 10-15 years that's
what I like to think about and could be
a problem but you know be cool to be
working at like sub 5 meter globally in
a little bit so I'm just going to show
you a little background with modus
notice we practice our algorithms with
the data that were available in the 90s
and 2000 so avhrr motifs daily
observations the land surface how do you
process these that you get through the
clouds we're working in the optical
domain so we don't route working with
the radar how do you get through the
clouds see the land surface characterize
it and see how it changes through time
so this is a single day's acquisition of
as a polar orbiting satellite that
orbits come apart at the equator CC have
these gaps they overlap at the poles
take these data and make cloud-free
imagery that are we call metrics so you
try and selectively pick the right
observations that allow you to see the
vegetation cover of the surface and then
turn that into characterizations this is
example of a forest cover loss product
for five years so that you take those
those those there's time series of
observations calibrate it with some
finer scale data and then come up with a
quantification of a dynamic at a global
scale this is very coarse but it's a
it's a it's a result that we
we characterize the uncertainty about
and and why is this valuable even at
this course scale well you know to date
are our global environmental data come
from groups like FAO they have the
mandate to do global environmental
whether it's forestry or agricultural
statistics and you look at the globe you
see North America very quiet and there's
no change going on there and that's
because they use a land use criterion in
the forest domain and whether it's
whether they're trees there or not it's
still a forest from a forestry
perspective so they don't call a lot of
the dynamics occurring in North America
change the point being that fao because
countries submit their own statistics
and there is not a consistent definition
what you call a tree in Namibia is not
what you call a tree in Congo it's hard
to get a global story and the FAO data
are round and I feel kind of sorry for
the FAO because they have to deal with
this inconsistency and try to come up
with a synthesis but when we look at the
satellite in terms of disturbance we see
that places like Canada have as much
disturbance as Brazil the USA in terms
of proportion of disturbance given a
reference forest area is the highest
disturbance level four countries with
over a million square kilometers of
forest so the satellite allows us to do
apples to apples quantitative
comparisons so what we've done is we've
moved onto land sap and we've tested
this product that tested our methods
moving down to 30 meters at a whole host
of different biomes European Russia to
Mexico to Indonesian I'm going to go
through some of those examples right now
but the key thing this is why you know
for a lot of biodiversity applications
we're at a fairly coarse scale even at
30 meters but we have a certain set of
criteria we're going to do global
monitoring we actually have to have data
globally so you have to have systematic
acquisitions and modis and landsat are
systematically being acquired a lot of
European sensors their commercial you
task them by project the Brazilian
sensors are are not there's not there's
not a global receiving network right now
for them so NASA instruments in USGS in
terms of Landsat for does this
capability like what he said they're
they're available now no low cost these
30 meter data so we can access the
archived and mine the entire archive we
used to what you used to write a paper
just on one image now we can stack up
10,000
hundred thousand five hundred thousand
images i'll show a test of using over
half a million images a little bit easy
access and preprocessing already done so
there's a certain set of criteria that
allows us to do global monitoring I'm
going to show just some of the issues
related to you know there it is a this
digital image processing you have to
have some expertise in it this stuff is
not off the shelf so I we do use a set
of Corrections we evaluate every pixel
to try and assess its quality it's a big
long chain of processes not a big not
germane to this but I just to make sure
that you know we're truck we have to
automate these procedures evaluate them
and test them so this is a modus
cloud-free image is the kind of data
that we use to integrate integration for
me is not the kind of what he's talking
about it's like lotus and landsat and
other other satellite data sets we try
to integrate different observations to
create a way to process data
automatically so this is old slide but
it kind of catchers the idea you might
get raw data that looks like this over
the Congo Basin how do you map the Congo
Basin consistently so they change you
map in the southeast corner of katanga
province is the same that you get up in
inequity province india in the DRC and
and we have a set of corrections that
are you know kind of hard there will
they are hard-wired where we go through
and we get rid of we try and create a
top of canopy look correct for an
isotropy or bi-directional reflections
distribution function effects composite
temporally and so pretty soon you know
you get this picture like i can map that
and i can monitor at that scale so it's
all about the technical kind of
automation of the pre-processing and
then our goal is you know this is what
we would have with modus a 250 meter we
can get our 30 meter data looking the
same way i can apply my algorithms that
we are using globally with modus to data
with such as landsat so that's the idea
from a kind of technical standpoint we
also need to do QA is very important i
want to show you some examples
conceptually why it's a challenge to map
the globe and it has to do it has to do
with clouds basically in our domain but
Brazil and Australia are the state of
the art in terms of forest monitoring
most of my examples are forced for this
talk and Brazil has
this seasonal dry season that gives you
a cloud free window July August
timeframe and they take each each year
they get a clean image and they compare
that to the last year's image and they
map the bulk of the arc of deforestation
where the big dynamics are occurring
Australia's saying the same way the real
cloudy partner Australia's has mania
that's where the radar people make a
living all right they work in Tasmania
and it's all based on single date
imagery because they can count on it
when you go to higher latitudes look at
the arc of deforestation about 12
degrees south this is matt a girl so
this is the equator you go into the
Congo you go to Indonesia you got
problems in terms of getting cloud-free
data so that's what the arc of
deforestation looks like in southern
Brazil matter Grosso state here's
Indonesia so to tell you show you our
problem this was our and this is why
data policy is a big deal and why having
an open archive is a big deal because
when we look at a single path row this
is the observational kind of element of
Al and sets of the lancet sensor this is
a year's worth of data for area in east
kalimantan on the island of Borneo in
Indonesia
so you might want to start out saving
the orangutans you become an atmospheric
chemist or something right you step it's
really hard to see this too so there's
no cloud free data and the idea is how
do we but there are literally millions
of good observations in these data and
we have to filter them and find them and
we can make this kind of product where
we see through the clouds by stacking up
good observations evaluating them and
mapping the change in red on terms of
the forest disturbance over the over a
five-year period so again high volume
data processing with the taking
advantage of the open data policy and
then we go through our characterization
validation we map and document change so
in Indonesia this is an example of a
we've done ten years now I think this is
an eight-year product where we're
mapping and you see this West East
disturbance where Sumatra's and the kind
of clean-up operation of all the lowland
forest cali monton is on its way by the
time you get out to Papua New Guinea
it's just inroads just selective logging
roads going up up into the interior of
the island and we map the change in
aggregate sense and then we disaggregate
it annually now here's what's cool about
having 30 meter data globally we're
going to map all these disturbances and
we're going to know the ages of these
forests we're going to keep a record of
all the disturbance history of each of
these parcels so imagine that you have a
30 meter record and we could push this
back a little bit it's more about moving
forward that we're going to have these
these data in a more practical sense
being able to do it but kind of a land
use history or disturbance history / / /
parcel of land this place right here was
clear twice in 10 years and we see that
we map it and record that and the value
is when you put it over let's say land
use zoning polygons and so there's a
couple zoning polygons in Indonesia that
are where forest loss or just logging
and clearings illegal but when we map
our change on top of these two island
groups Sumatran comment time we get
almost ten percent occurring in these
land uses limited production forests are
also where it's supposed to be selective
logging but clearing happens and has
been increasing so here's a
limited-production forest here's these
conservation forest contributing
considerable amount of disturbance to
the total for the country and this for
biodiversity is obviously a big deal
because the protection force are the
national parks
we also put the change in context of
references in terms of intactness so we
we have a method for getting a frame of
reference when we start the monitoring
to say that you know a certain portion
of sumatra is intact in other words it
has no evidence of human infrastructure
no roads no settlements and so this is a
high biodiversity high carbon target and
so we go through a process to map that
and that would be these dark green
forests that have have not had recent
historical change and we map how those
are lost over time and then these become
targets for future monitoring if you see
a logging road going into these polygons
that's a big bigger deal from
biodiversity and or carbon perspective
so this kind of product a pan tropically
is something that we're working on now
as well the other cool thing about these
data is that when you map an algorithm
at a continent or a global scale you get
real boundaries along administrative
units so you see governance you see
markets that play across different units
so when we go into to the center of
Borneo we see the Malaysia very
aggressive in terms of clearing right up
to the boundary with Indonesia even
though Indonesia is the one you always
hear about because they are a developing
country a lot of part of the red
mechanism a lot of investment there
Malaysia doesn't have that and and
they're kind of management therefore
it's very different much more aggressive
in terms of exploiting the timber
Democratic Republic of the Congo totally
different story have a war about three
to five million people dead in 15 years
not a lot of data but there are we work
with conservation groups work in
priority landscapes across the Congo
Basin mapping the change inside and
outside of those landscapes working with
conservation is to assess biodiversity
richness like john hart of the wildlife
conservation society uses our data to go
target the biodiversity transects
finding new species of bat like in a
tone blame a thief and different things
so it's a nice collaboration with the
big inge ngos and then looking at
changes inside and outside of parks and
if you see a place like this where these
dark colors are high rates of change
here's a park near that Kinshasa the
capital where there's greater change
inside the park than a buffer around the
park so these are like hollowed out
parks that are not retaining any kind of
the forest structure
in terms of concept conserving and
keeping a disturbance outside of it
here's a Verona National Park a big big
you know tragedy there with a lot of
displaced persons and charcoal being
being cut and an agriculture encroaching
in terms inside virunga national parks
you see a front of disturbance violating
the integrity of the park so these type
of data obviously bringing meaning again
in a kind of regional context across the
Congo Basin we also do another other
other regions again we're working
towards a generic implementation so this
is the United States with Landsat data
this is called the well data set being
produced at South Dakota State
University and producing forest cover
and a series of different cover of
dynamics and so here's the here's an
example of force cover loss for the
United States over a four-year period
and I just want to show this example
here real quickly this is a measure of
what week would call for poor force or
something related to recent intactness
so if we take all the forests and we and
we kind of penalize areas that are force
that are in proximity to change we see
this huge you know basically the force
of the southeast and most people know
this it's basically trees our cropland
there and there's no real extent of
force that is that is absent of change
when you get in the mid-atlantic up into
New England we have these force that
have been intact for a long time the
best echo region in terms of lack of
change and kind of forest extent is in
the Adirondacks here we have some other
ones up in the northwest so this idea
the global scale we can map these force
that are not changing and that are
changing and then try to say something
about habitat integrity potential and so
we've labeled the the kind of high core
forest echo regions the median and then
us the low and all these low ones that
have a lot of force but it's continually
cycling in and out very different
structure very different floristic
compositions because it's a commercial
endeavor are all in the southeast us
to highlight that we do stuff beyond
forestry this is bare ground and it
really is a strange it's it's a
different kind of product but the idea
is to map where vegetation is lost
permanently to a bare grant 202 kind of
a development conversion this could be
mining it could be an airport extension
could be a road and the interesting
thing about these kind of products is a
they're just they're just cool I mean
they talk about the airport's being the
future downtown the CBD of the future if
it defender builds their Airport 30
miles outside of the city it's not a big
deal the city will grow to it because
that is the way you connect to the world
and a lot of these initial products in
terms of the United States and bare
ground change is reflecting that
airports are kind of like this this
center of conversion but again doing
this globally seeing all the
urbanization occurring in China all of
the developing world mega cities growing
this is the type of data that will help
us map that footprint okay we've tested
this algorithm globally and we're
working towards a global implementation
and then you know it's early days but we
have some very kind of a convincing
results and i'll tell you when you pan
around a product you see that there's
very few landscapes we don't mess with I
it's incredible I mean if you talk about
Scandinavia candidate you name it the
pipe I think maybe then as well it might
be one place where there's not a lot of
changes it's it's pervasive everywhere
so I'm going to take a virtual transect
from Canada to the US to Central America
Brazil and then Argentina and Chile and
what we see and this is that this is a
global run just a test a test global run
but here's a red is lost in this area of
Canada and Quebec blue is gains we're
doing both the net the loss in the game
to get net and a lot of times in the
high latitudes when they log it it
doesn't come back for 70 200 years so we
don't see a strong regrowth signal here
in 10 years this is a 10-year result
here's Alabama plus and minus and look
at that pervasive I mean what what does
that mean for biodiversity that rate of
change in 10 years 80 kilometer by 60
kilometer the whole Southeast is like
that if you've driven through the
southeast just some backcountry Road you
see the force there
they're they're used I'll just put it
that way here's an example from Central
America where we have Belize and you
could see the border of Guatemala here
coming out so you see these trans
national boundary effects everywhere you
see certain levels of kind of scale of
change it might be smallholder versus
industrial but interesting dynamics to
kind of quantify this is a nice example
because it's one of the places that we
haven't seen cloud-free so this is the
western coast of Colombia I just clued
that in there because if you're a remote
sensing geeky really excited to see a
place that you can't see typically
agroforestry in southern Brazil place
where it's not a forest environment but
they've they've introduced eucalyptus
and and other species for forestry this
is true deforestation in the Chaco there
are places in the last 10 years and
chacos one of them where the rates of
change is there there we haven't
quantified this data yet we're still
validating it but the rates of change
are unprecedented and it's deforestation
of entire ecosystem from Paraguay from
Bolivia through Paraguay down to
Argentina all to do you know 10
kilometer by five kilometers soybean
fields to sell soybeans to China in
Cambodia we see rates of change that we
haven't quantified but double-digit
clearing inside national parks so it's
this big alarm going off I would say the
story is quite quite you know scary and
then chili just incredible agroforestry
so we have this crazy dynamic land
service in the force much less
agriculture this is an example we had
Jane Goodall come by a week ago and we
just panned around our product and
looked at some some different ideas you
know just the the the the way these data
reflect certain dynamics and the forest
cover in the context of a new initiative
there is to do a habitat health
assessment so they whether they're
chimpanzees there or not they want
identify these parcels of forest they
have potential for being good habitat
see how they're connected to other
parcels in terms of corridors and we
just panned around and looked at a few
examples and i'm going to show you what
those look like right now so we zoom
into
the western southwestern corner of cote
divoire this is thai national parks if
you saw the disney movie chimpanzee this
is where those chimpanzees were and our
change alarm are changed product for the
last ten years is in red here so you can
see it kind of envelops the park here is
a park that is hollowed out so not only
do you see transnational effects in
terms of rates of change you see it
within countries where the governance of
the protection of this area doesn't
exist in thai national park really
looking good we go down to the next then
when they look at the imagery there's
the thai forest all intact and that's a
bet good news that it has integrity the
Lillian Panetta of a Jane Goodall said
that's fine but you know when disease
it's this there's not going to be a way
to escape it there could be there could
be a big you know just a litter a shin
of the chimp population here's Liberia a
good potential habitat but no real
status and there's some concern that
these forests are going to be logged
soon there was something to do so anyway
yeah this nice story about the
differential rates of impact and
governance and how that affects habitat
for chimps we're going to zoom down here
to the coast of Central Africa this is a
cool example because this is an exclave
of angle it's called Cabinda and there's
no change in there it's really kind of
an outlier from the rest of the country
this hasn't seen a lot of development
this is the lower Congo that has a lot
of population pressure and even though
this is a reserve the forests have all
been degraded there and so the Jane
Goodall folks want to think about adding
this area is it to a corridor going
north through the lesser populated
Republic of Congo in Gabon and if I go
back and forth you can see that boundary
coming out so Cabinda is a good site and
they know that there are chimpanzees in
these in these forests and so here's the
border and Congo is right out right out
of the loop as a potential harbor of
chimpanzees one last example this is
bonobo country not chimpanzee country
the pygmy chimpanzee here's an example
of a place that changed 30 years ago
it's this big void and you can see the
change around it and along these trunk
roads but in here you're going to see
click on the on the next slide this was
logged 30 years ago and there's a lot of
places that were logged in central
Africa and they left and biodiversity
return to these sites and they found a
good site in the Republic of Congo where
they found large numbers of primates
inside a previous log force so this idea
of time series not all change is the
same if we can if we can withstand some
logging and not have populations move in
and and kind of progressively them
appropriate the force for different land
uses this could be good habitat so just
another different idea okay so in
conclusion we're really psyched that
that really happy that we're working at
this medium resolution now 30 meters
we're going to be doing global land
cover change the scale of change is hard
to comprehend really and we're good but
we're going to get we're going to have
to develop models that accept these data
almost in near real-time and that's our
goal our goal is to come you know the
latest image comes down and we send out
a product that says this place changed
and whether it's a land manager or a
modeler hopefully can incorporate that
door that data either to improve the
model or to make a decision in terms of
how to how to better manage the resource
data policies critical to this kind of a
method the idea of the commercial domain
being less or equal to 5 meters and
that's where it is we're not going to do
global monitoring that way it costs too
much money and that's that's if that
scale is needed for certain applications
the only way I can conceive of it is
maybe with a targeted sample based
approach because it's just a huge land
surface and the costs are there they're
hard to imagine and so data policy
moving forward beyond 30 meters is a big
deal we have to validate our products
obviously we have to attribute the
change all of our disturbances not the
same you have fiery of disease you have
logging I mentioned this idea of all
changes are not equal so we're very
concerned at least from a conservation
our partners in the conservation world
in terms of primary intact loss we're
working in other cover dynamics and then
we also work with developing countries
because we want to give them ownership
over the process and have them advance
their capabilities for monitoring their
own countries not have us feed them the
results and that doesn't work at all
they don't accept it and rightly so they
want to they want to be in command of
their
and we're going down to Peru this week
to do an exercise of map ten years of
change of Peru and we've already got a
product but we in a week will have map
ten years of the country and they will
have driven the the kind of driven the
process then to think about where we'll
be in ten more years if we do move down
to this scale are we going to overcome
some of these data policy so that we can
move from 30 meters down to 5 meters
globally I think that's really exciting
but I don't know if it's a realistic
expectation thank you make the match
Matt super fascinating I hope you sort
of would agree with me that this sort of
Technology this sort of research can be
a real game-changer for biodiversity
model and that's was my big motivation
for waiting maps to come up here I think
you can learn a lot here and you see
where this can be in five years from now
records like that so questions
of elevation
back in time Jesus great question well
you can help you with that uh when you
look backwards in time you typically the
validation you would like it to have be
derived from a finer a better reference
and so if I'm doing a 30 meter map I
would love to have a five metre
reference or something that would give
me a better sense of what I'm omitting
in terms of scale and all that kind of
stuff there is no systematic record at
that scale so it's hit and miss where
those data sets are in the US we look at
a like the last ten years even on Google
Earth there's great records there's
there's a agencies like Farm Service
Agency I think that's the one that does
regular aerial overpasses but globally
they're huge voids so we have to do like
with like if we go backwards it's
usually handcrafted Landsat where person
where an analyst works on something very
detailed using ancillary information
saying this is what happened the Sam is
working on that and he can share how
difficult that is the gentleman in front
of you but I'm moving forward I do like
the five meter or less targeted samples
and we'll nail that we will be very good
understanding our accuracy of these
algorithms prospectively historically we
have to use the data that fit that are
there and it's not going to be
statistically perfect Ron the other
question so many questions all the time
that erroneously head of our center of
earth observations here we are you
alluding to some new tools
land 7 i'd like to learn about but i
guess my question now is vertical
landsat gap and I wonder what's going to
happen to this Landsat time series okay
all all of those products will landsat-7
scanline corrector off so we use those
data and the gaps are like a cloud to us
so it's just a bad data we do it means
we have less observations there and in a
place that's really cloud impacted like
the coast the guinea coast of Africa we
see problems so so we don't we don't
consider it a gap right yet we're using
those data and then and then you know
Landsat 8 supposed to launch februari
whatever 12th and that'll be huge but
that's where we hold our thing in our
fingers crossed it'sit's eight-day
separate from from landsat 7 so we'll be
able to use those in concert so maybe
you know year from now we're rolling and
data and we're doing well it's all about
that launch if that works so you know
we're doing pretty well with a broken a
broken instrument and when we add Lance
that say eight to it it's going to be
stellar we're excited about it
if you like we were different
and all
that's a fish
really
yeah I think so i think when i look at
at the economics socioeconomics that's
what I see in governance and places like
Africa the forest structure is intact
because it's so poorly governed and and
you know it Mozambique and Angola stick
out of the stick out of the satellite
because they're at war for 25 years and
nobody really exploited their force
Mozambique has a transition to democracy
then also in the global markets and then
also did start it starts changing
rapidly places that are wired to the
global market insular Southeast Asia
Malaysia Indonesia Argentina huge huge
changes I mean they're appropriating the
land and they're doing what we did I
guess a century ago so I think that's a
huge you know econometric whatever you
want to say it's not my expertise but
hopefully you know rd is to get these
data out and people can make those kind
of analyses but that's what you see I
can't really build on it more than that
it's really interesting so how can we
access your products and you can commit
right we're in the process of validating
the global product some of our products
are online or European Russia product or
our congo product so that you know but
they're kind of just just hit and miss
the global product I would imagine in
the next three to three to six months
we're going to have that out and and
hopefully as well imagery so the people
you know can can play with their own
their own algorithms to see what they
can make of it as well and that's
another thing I'll mention that they
were getting rid of in the next cut in
the coming years USGS has an initiative
within the data called weld where
they're going to you we're not going to
using path row anymore with Landsat
you're going to get modis type tiles
you're going to be able to do your own
algorithms not have to worry about all
this hand-holding and processing so
that's a big deal i think five years
from now there will be more democratic
in terms of how many people can use
these data with it with a not a key
steep learning curve I think remote
sensing communities still large take
things back so particular time just one
day to fun
I think we're getting a point now
that we're never returned to think about
terminal accuracy but the community that
way
thinking about two points in time and so
some of the maps q show
maybe it's three points but I think
there's a big disconnect between some of
the algorithm development in terms of
conceptualize change and then also I
think there's another issue around how
do we start thinking about and applying
technology across different biomes
thinking about training data including
question early about accuracy assessment
so can you talk a little bit about how
these are originals of the North
thinking right now
right that's great great question um we
do take this approach where I mean we're
more interested in the change actually
than just a static land cover map and so
you know I can take a decade's worth
observation stack them up and look for
the change inside that that record and
then backtrack in a retrospectively
backtrack when the when the change
occurred so like an Indonesian a place
that's forest it is cleared in two
thousand cleared in 2002 grows back in
2006 clear in 2009 you have that kind of
dynamic in a very cloudy place so it's
really strange I mean you will never get
a single year composite image that's
clean and Indonesia so it's a really
difficult thing and so the only way we
really thought to do it was to stack
everything together and try and go
directly for change I think validation
for change is is similar to 22 doing a
static map I mean the statistics behind
it and everything are the challenge with
changes if you do it over to find a time
step changes so such a small fraction of
the land surface that your heirs if
you're at wrong at all you blow up your
your estimate so in other words like in
the in the Congo Basin if it's a half a
percent change I could easily double
that with my algorithm and then then you
have a hundred percent error regarding
change so change is a difficult thing to
validate over ten years the amount of
change we're seeing I think we can I
think we can have uncertainty bounds
around our estimate that don't make our
map look like garbage but but yeah we're
doing the same methods of validation but
just for a change class and that class
is for us lost could be for is gain
whatever what was your second point I
thought that was there was a good
question too
it's bracketed it happened inside that
period it's not a time one time to thing
it happens sometime in between that's
the way we think of it because if you
took a time one image in time to image
you'll miss a lot of change in between
you you will in some of the tropical
areas but you had a second point that I
that I liked it what was it all right Oh
phonology yes so with motifs we we we
can affect ignore phonology we've been
our data on temperature on greenness all
these kind of all these different kind
of rule sets and we can create a global
image that looks clean without regard
without regards to time of year or
phenology it's really quite neat Landsat
not so clean this first test we've used
modus to define growing season and we
will be focused on growing season off
season is really valuable in a lot of
places but the acquisition of Landsat is
really even though it's a global
strategy it's inconsistent place to
place and it's hard to to it to ignore
phenology like we do with motifs we
really ignore it with motifs and in
Lance that we have to pay you know we
have a little bit of sweet spot that's
consistent globally and it's it's a
little harder I don't think but i can
tell you explain a little bit more of it
but we you know phonology should not
impact our change results is the point
that's that we work very hard to make
sure that doesn't happen well unless
there any super critical urgent
questions to either mapped or any of the
previous speakers there's anything on
your mind we can prep spring it up again
in the afternoon session have a little
general discussion at the end